il y a eu beaucoup de spéculation
beaucoup d'incompréhension aussi sur
l'état de l'accusé pendant drame après
le drame je parle évidemment du drame de
Laval pour en parler je joins la docteur
Marie Frédéric Allard et les psychiatre
légiste elle est aussi membre du conseil
d'administration de l'Association des
médecins psychres bonjour Marie Frédéric
alors je le dis beaucoup de spéculations
sur sa santé mentale mais en réalité il
n'en a pas subi d'évaluations
psychiatrique est-ce qu'on devra en
faire une à un certain point si on veut
en avoir le cœur net oui
j'espère en fait je pense que il y a
deux aspects il y a savoir on a parlé
hier de l'attitude à comparaître qu'on
comprend c'est qu'il a comparé devant la
Cour le juge de questionner puis ils ont
arrivés à la conclusion que monsieur
était hâte sauf que l'aptitude à
comparer c'est une question qui peut
être soulevée à tout moment pendant le
processus judiciaire donc si à un moment
donné dans une semaine dans deux
semaines il retourne à la cour si on
avocat à des inquiét il peut redemander
une version comparées ça c'est une chose
donc c'est savoir si on comprend ce qui
se passe à la cour bon évidemment tout
le monde on comprend ça tout le monde
est présumé sain d'esprit donc apte à
comparaître mais qu'est-ce qui indique
le contraire est-ce qu'il y a des signes
apparents de personnes qui ne seraient
pas aptes qui serait possible d'esprit
mais souvent les tribunaux vont se
questionner sur l'attitude bon quand les
gens ont des antécédents qui sont connus
pour une maladie psychiatrique qui
pourrait faire en sorte qu'il soit
inapte dans un trouble psychotique
lorsqu'il y a une désorganisation
comportementale que les gens sont pas
capables de respecter le décorum de la
cour qui sont très méfiants qui refusent
de collaborer entre autres quelqu'un qui
deviendrait très agité devant le
tribunal une déficience intellectuelle
un trouble cognitif quand l'avocat aussi
peut dire j'ai rencontré mon client puis
j'ai de la difficulté à communiquer avec
lui ça c'est un motif d'évaluation
évidemment celui qu'on a décrit hier
était désorganisé au moment de
l'arrestation donc tôt hier matin et là
on leur vu moi je l'ai vu à 16h45 quand
il a comparu de son lit d'hôpital il
était calme et je me suis demandé
comment est-ce qu'on peut l'avoir calmer
ou réorganiser en si peu de temps mais
c'est assurément pour ça qu'on le
conduit à l'hôpital d'ailleurs parce
qu'il était agité
oui
on peut émettre l'hypothèse qui a reçu
une médication le cas même plusieurs
traitements pharmacologiques qui peuvent
aider à calmer une personne des belles
Audi azépines des antibiotiques et que
ça peut être une des raisons qui ont
fait que Monsieur c'est Camille des fois
quand il y a de l'agitation très très
importante et policier bon utiliser
l'horaire d'impulsion électrique
c'est sûr que ça ça calme beaucoup
mais ce que je comprends si les
informations que j'ai eu c'est qu'il
s'est désorganisé quand même plus tard
ou je sais pas si c'était après sa
comparution mais pendant la comparution
ils ont suspendu un moment et quand ils
sont revenus le policier a dit que
l'accusé l'avait frappé alors évidemment
tout le monde a été un peu sous le choc
et alors mais frapper comment il l'a pas
fait de grandes descriptions l'agent
mais c'est ce que vous appelez ce
désorganiser à nouveau
oui ça peut être des organisés à nouveau
puis des fois aussi dans le processus je
tiens ça va vite les comparutions ça
dure pas une heure une ligne de demi
heure on peut l'avoir questionner
rapidement mais que finalement c'est
quand il va rencontrer son avocat qui va
faire peut-être une rencontre un peu
plus poussée qui va peut-être avoir
d'autres motifs de redemander latitude
ça c'est une chose c'est là en ce moment
mais il va
dépendamment la stratégie d'avocat mais
il peut avoir aussi une demande
d'évaluation de la responsabilité que
c'est là que je vous amenais justement
parce que on pense on pense pareil il
m'arrive Frédéric alors il y a
l'attitude à subir son procès et il y a
la non responsabilité criminelle c'est
deux choses complètement différentes à
quel moment l'avocat de la défense peut
invoquer ce moyen de défense parce que
ça en est un moyen de défense là il va
lui falloir une expertise
tout à fait il peut avoir deux moyens
d'avoir une expertise il peut demander à
que la Cour leur donne donc le patient
va être envoyé dans un établissement
désigné de bon sur l'île de Montréal
prendre un Pinel ou si c'est ailleurs au
Québec il y a d'autres établissements ou
l'avocat peut faire une demande pour une
expertise qu'on appelle privée
applique directement un psychiatre tu
dirais ce que vous voudriez aller
rencontrer mon client mettons en
détention puis faire votre évaluation
tout ça deux impacts différents parce
que si c'est la cour
l'expert qui va le PS4 qui va faire
l'expertise va remettre son expertise au
juge et aux deux parties tandis que si
c'est une demande privée ça va être à la
demande de l'avoir quand même qu'il a
demandé effectivement bon évidemment les
gens entretiennent toutes sortes de de
théories sur les défenses de non
responsabilité criminels mais c'est pas
simple présenter ça le fardeau et l'eau
parce que on peut être dérangé on peut
avoir des troubles mentaux mais être
quand même responsable de ces gestes et
je repense évidemment au cas de magnotta
personne pensait que magnotta était sain
d'esprit pour avoir fait ce qu'il a fait
mais au final il savait ce qu'il faisait
il était responsable de ces gestes donc
ces deux choses complètement distinctes
il y a des dans la responsabilité
criminelle l'article 5 du Code criminel
il y a des degrés donc un trouble mental
c'est quand même assez large un trouble
mental qu'ensuite il y a des critères
savoir ce qu'on savait ce qu'on faisait
est-ce qu'on était capable d'appliquer
de raisonnablement bon Dieu il y a
plusieurs critères donc on embarque pas
mais il faut quand même avoir une
intensité de de trouble mental puis
ensuite il faut que cette défense là
aussi passe devant un jury ou un juge
puis capte c'est une moyenne défense qui
est invoquée c'est la défense qui a le
fardeau de la preuve donc il y a
vraiment plusieurs marches à monter
avant qu'un individu soit reconnu donc
finalement responsable
qui surtout s'il y a une contre
expertise bon ça augmente aussi la
difficulté parce qu'on se retrouve avec
deux des experts qui ont pas tout à fait
la même avis
à plusieurs
occasions d'ailleurs d'ailleurs il y a
toujours une contre-expertise en fait il
y a toujours un psychiatre pour la
couronne si c'est une défense qu'on
évoque oui surtout quand c'est grave si
je vous dirais dans
les accusations beaucoup moins graves
puis des fois c'est beaucoup plus
évident il y a pas de contexpertise mais
dans ce genre d'évaluation de contexte
c'est clair qui c'est une expertise qui
est présentée par la défense il va avoir
une contre expertise absolument Marie
Frédéric Allard c'est toujours
extrêmement limpide merci beaucoup de
nous avoir parlé
coucou bonne fin de journée pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI